les alliés ne venge pas sur le fond de
salonique ni en italie mais ils se
maintiennent ils veulent profiter de la
flambée des nationalismes qui sont
souvent en leur faveur
nationalistes sont les serbes des slaves
du sud qui sont à l'origine de cette
guerre nationaliste et pas schiste qui
veut constituer une yougoslavie
indépendante de l'autriche hongrie
nationaliste et km weizmann hommes de
sciences britannique qui veut constituer
la nation d'israël au proche orient sur
le nationalisme arabe compte le colonel
lawrence alors lieutenant il veut réunir
tous les arabes et les lancers contre
les turcs
il y réussit assez bien
les jeunes turcs aussi sont
nationalistes et se refuse à briser
l'unité de leur pays aidés et conduit
par les officiers leurs armes et
s'affirme sur tous les fronts elle est
bien dotée par les allemands en matériel
de guerre en particulier d'artillerie
elle passe à l' attaque tous azimuts en
1915 un veut à la fois prendre suez est
découragée par tous les angles et son
objectif est le symbole de la présence
britannique dans cette zone le canal de
suez il est gardé par des troupes de l'
empire et par des unités de la royal
navy
en février 1915 une forces turques de
20000 homme s'est levé comme un vent de
sable
elle est parvenue jusqu'aux défense
anglaise du canal
la flotte anglaise tirs
les turcs sont partis mais on sait
désormais qu'en méditerranée
il faut compter avec les nationalismes
tous ces peuples ne sont pas satisfaits
de bonnes paroles
ils veulent retrouver leur paradis perdu
même pas
les allemands décidé de faire face aux
situations nouvelles créées au sud de
l'europe vers l'automne 1915
ils peuvent compter sur leurs propres
armes et sur quelques unités
autrichienne et sur les bulgares qui
sont entrés dans la guerre il dispose de
très solides sunnite et d'un armement
lourd en canon krupp et d'une longue
habitude de la guerre contre leurs
voisins balkaniques
le bloc des puissances centrales est
désormais constituée allemagne autriche
hongrie bulgarie et la turquie
le général aogo spawn mac and then est
chargé du commandement nord riant il le
partage avec un autre général que les
français connaissent bien
eric von fall kane qui commandait et qui
a échoué
un ver dans cette armée doit s'ouvrir la
route de constantinople qui ne peut être
qu'une route de terre parce que les
alliés etienne la mer un obstacle
pourtant sur le parcours la nation serbe
farouchement hostile aux puissances
centrales
c'est une évidence stratégique aux yeux
de falco nine la serbie doit sauter
trois pierres de serbie et vieux malade
mais résolue son fils le régent
alexandre a été éduqué en russie
tsariste leur premier ministre est un
vieil homme pas schiste qui a programmé
la guerre des serbes contre les austro
hongrois détester
l'empiré d'autriche hongrie a voulu par
deux fois écrasé la serbie il n'y a pas
réussi et il brûle de recommencer
tous
comment
là
cette fois des moyens très importants
sont mises en jeu la serbie est à feu et
à sang levin sont détruites par les
bombes les villages incendiés
l'armée royale et impériale d'autriche
hongrie néglige rien pour raser le pays
les chefs envisage une retraite le long
de la mer pour échapper aux autrichiens
et aux allemands et aussi aux bulgares
qui veulent leur part de gâteau les
serbes jure de revenir pour former leurs
camps royaume des serbes des croates et
des slovènes
en attendant les autrichiens avance
occupent le pays slaves
suivent le cours des rivières le danube
la morava la serbie disent les
autrichiens est un serpent qu'il faut
écraser
obama
les serbes sont en retraite une armée de
deux cent mille hommes recul en ordre
d'un champ de sauver ces bataillons pas
de transport pas de vivre une munition
l'armée traîne avec elle une centaine de
canon et 24000 autrichien prisonniers le
vieux roi est en voiture un peu entraîne
dans une chaise à porteurs le chef de
l'armée qui souffre la marche dure
longtemps très longtemps
deux mois de marche beaucoup perdent
leurs chaussures dans la neige
boncourt les pieds gelés d'autres
meurent de froid dans cette retraite
héroïque on mange les chevaux les
villageois suivent les soldats pour ne
pas tomber aux mains des bulgares la
retraite héroïque des serbes c'est un
peu l'équivalent de la retraite des
belges en août 14 et droit des serbes
ressemble singulièrement au roi
chevalier le roi de belgique la retraite
des serbes
c'est un peu le fantôme de la nation
oh
les serbes essaye de gagner à travers
les montagnes la frontière grecque où
ils sont sûrs d'être bien accueillies la
grèce n'est pas belligérantes mais elle
est amicale et les alliés combattants à
salonique
malheureusement les serbes cherche enfin
une mission allier ils en trouvent pas
et doivent gagner les montagnes
d'albanie vers l'ouest peut être
trouveront ils les alliés dans le port
de durazzo ils y sont mais pour
embarquer toute l'armée serbe il n'y a
que quelques bateaux on les emmène tout
de même dans l'île de corfou 70000 sont
morts en chemin cent quarante mille
survivent souvent bien amaigri ou
malades ils sont enfin secourus et
soigné encadrait pour repartir au combat
à salonique ils veulent se battre au
plus tôt ils ont leur patrie à
reconquérir
oh
l'armée de salonique est une tour de
babel on y parle toutes les langues de
la coalition des alliés dans le port les
transports de troupes
les cargos amène sans arrêt des renforts
du matériel du ravitaillement au risque
d'être torpillé en méditerranée par les
sous marins allemands les italiens après
l'entrée en guerre de leur pays ont
rejoint les alliés les serbes arrivent
les russes sont déjà là les grecs ont
des volontaires car le roi des grecs
hésitent à entrer dans le conflit a
quitté la position très avantageuse pour
lui de la neutralité
les alliés sont à la fois ses invités
ses otages
quand le président de la république
raymond poincaré habillé en chauffeur à
son habitude visite la base il trouve
une armée internationale très bien
organisée qui veut percer dans les
balkans selon le vieux rêve de quartier
il n'y a malheureusement pas de vue
stratégique précise pour cette armée les
serbes sont seuls motivés ils veulent
reconquérir leur pays vallée après
vallée en franchissant les montagnes ils
veulent créer la yougoslavie cet
objectif l'armée de salonique
l'acceptent
elle mettra deux ans pour l'atteindre un
autre front stagnant vient d'être créée
ici à saint lô blick
les anglais ont besoin de troupes pour
faire face au tueur dans le proche
orient ou lempire de constantinople
exercer sa souveraineté jusqu'en syrie
et jusqu'en palestine
les turcs sont désormais en liaison
directe avec berlin leur chef est un
général de l'armée allemande le bar en
crèche fans crient sunstein c'est un de
ses assistants techniques qui organise
l'armée turque bien doter en matériel
bien encadré et qui peut faire front
la force expéditionnaire égyptienne
s'avance dans le désert pour établir
dans le sinaï
une ligne de défense contre les turcs et
les empêcher d'atteindre suez artère
vitale pour l'économie de guerre
britannique
bon
saatchi ballmer et à partir du caire
commente cette force expéditionnaire de
4e division anglaise et indienne
n'avancez lente prudentes les
britanniques construit en même temps un
chemin de fer et un pipe line d'eau
potable ils ne veulent pas mourir de
soif ou de faim
m
les anglais deviennent plus ambitieux en
avançant les approvisionnements leur
arrive régulièrement par les ports
méditerranéens
un nouveau front prend tournure
pourquoi ne pas concevoir une vaste
offensive le ministère de la guerre est
frustré il n'obtient aucune décision en
france on décide de pousser en attaque
le général maurin l'idée est d'envahir
lempire turc à partir de sa province la
plus méridionale celle de palestine une
sorte de reconquête de la terre sainte
le corps expéditionnaire atteint déjà
les frontières de palestine
il est aidé par une formidable rebellion
des peuples arabes qui se lève comme le
vent à 400 kilomètres au sud le long de
la péninsule d'arabie
cette masse de paix doit un tac et
triplé garnison turc campe sur les votes
communication avance comme une tornade
oui
hussein un cheikh arabe rallye autour de
lui les tribus
l'un de ses fils le prince fayçal et
rallier par l'officier anglais lawrence
laurent c'est un petit homme à la fois
archaïque et plein d'ironie fascinant il
a très mal réussi dans les bureaux de
l'armée au caire cet expert des a fait
un rab donner des avis qu'on n'avait pas
envie d'entendre et demandait une
stratégie pour la guerre ce qui choquait
beaucoup laurence enragé d'avoir un chef
aussi timorés il avait envie d'aller de
l'avant avec ses amis arabes ils étaient
sûrs d'eux
cet exhibitionniste s'habillait comme
les arabes est monté à dos de chameau
cobble hill parler leur langue épouse
edith leur mars et des plaisait fort au
général murray par son côté amateur
certains disaient charlatan un jeune
correspondant de guerre américains à
l'evel thomas a pour lui la plus vive
admiration
laurence ne laisse pas indifférent rider
déjà sacré lawrence d'arabie c'est une
étonnante mutation pour un officier de
sa majesté que devenir un prince arabe
laurence fait de la rébellion des chefs
arabes un mouvement puis une armée de
guérilla pour dynamiser les arabes il
leur promet de reconstituer au nord sur
les débris de lempire turc
l'ancien royaume des arabes ce rêve il
le fait partager un fait ça quand sera
l'artisan me dit il
tu seras le roi des arabes lawrence n'a
aucune idée de ce que feront plus tard
les diplomates
il veut seulement porter tous les arabes
vers le nord dans un tourbillon
il n'y réussit que trop bien les marches
vers le nord en suivant la côte de la
mer rouge pour stimuler le zèle des
hésitants arabe
les engrais gaspille du nord laurence
arrive devant aqaba dont les défenses
sont simples il attaquera de l'intérieur
tout réussit à laurence les bédouins
prennent tpiy yakapa il devient un
interlocuteur sérieux pour le général
mort et qui lui demande de participer à
la campagne de palestine et de rejoindre
la colonie anglaise déjà engagés
il doublera vers l'est en avançant dans
le désert la colonne anglaise qui suit
la côte objectif jérusalem naville
promises promises aujourd'hui aux juifs
3000 d'entre eux s'engagent dans l'armée
anglaise 3000 sur les cinquante mille
colons de palestine un tiers de ces
juifs de palestine ont échappé aux
pogroms du tsar ils sont répartis en 40
colonies soutenu par les juifs
d'occident ces sommes sont l'avant-garde
du sionisme ils cultivent des terres
achetées aux turcs payé rubis sur
l'ongle des terres sauvages et inculte
gagne à la culture au prix d'efforts
inouïe
le sionisme à ses porte parole dans les
démocraties occidentales
sont éloquentes avocat aux etats-unis et
louis brandeis plus tard wilson l'offre
entrée à la cour suprême
le réfugiés russes km weissman qui
milite pour le sionisme en grande
bretagne est un ami de lloyd george ce
chimiste a inventé un nouvel explosive
pour la guerre lionel walter rothschild
n'est pas seulement un banquet de
l'illustre famille mais un naturaliste
est un philanthrope
c'est à lui que balfour écrit le 2
novembre 1917 alors qu'ils les
secrétaires aux affaires étrangères
la lettre de balfour exprime en termes
vagues l'engagement de l'angleterre dans
l'idée sioniste
la déclaration de balfour et rendue
publique
la campagne de jérusalem commence alors
un très jeune général anglais qui
cherche la gloire allen b qu'on lui la
bataille
allenby veut avoir tous les juifs avec
lui il a décidé de battre fall kane le
bourreau des serbes qui a échoué à
verdun
dans le désert de palestine les unités
s'entretuent pour des points d'eau dans
des combats acharnés par une chaleur
terrifiante
quand les turcs perdent leurs points
d'eau ils sont déjà vaincue par la
malaria la dysenterie
ils ne peuvent plus combattre les
renforts leur parviennent de plus en
plus difficilement
laurence et ces guérillas gêne les
lignes de ravitaillement les lignes
turcs sont bientôt rompu
ouais
prenez jérusalem pour noël avait demandé
lloyd george allenby a deux semaines
d'avancé
il a lancé sa cavalerie à la charge dans
les collines de judée
les turcs ont évité de peu
l'encerclement l'artillerie lourde
britannique a fait merveille contre les
positions tueur les zac remarquable
cavaliers étaient déchaînés dans la
poursuite
le 11 décembre 1917 allenby entre à
jérusalem à pied comme un pèlerin suivi
tous ces combattants
il reçoit les clés de la ville des mains
des représentants des communautés
religieuses musulmanes chrétiennes et
juives
la palestine et libérez
les juives sont impatients d construire
un état karine weissmann arrive à
jérusalem en avril 10 218 avec une
délégation sur nist chargé de la
constitution de cet état juif
en face fait ça laissait arabe a dit
laurence a promis un royaume la
politique anglaise en est pas à une
contradiction près puisqu'elle soutient
à la fois le nationalisme arabe et la
revendication sur 10 tu ici en palestine
l'écrasement de lempire turc laisse aux
prises deux futurs ennemis
irréconciliables
les juifs et les arabes également pleins
d'espoir
aux etats-unis le président wilson
encourage les fortes caire et développe
dans la population
le réarmement moral il crée une agence
d'information du public que dirige le
journaliste georges grille on a recours
aux méthodes les plus modernes de
marketing utilisant tous les talents de
la dation pourfendre la politique du
président georges bru il assure
l'organisation de la campagne pour
populariser l'effort de guerre
avec toutes les recettes de la publicité
la maman
il engage john philip sousa et ses
tambours pour rythmer l'hymne à la
liberté et que chante en public
la soliste analyse
marie roberts winch hard l'écrivain du
mystère bien connu du grand public est
en reportage sur les champs de bataille
un auteur de best-sellers bouffe
tarkenton écrit sur les mensonges et
propagande allemande
la jeune romancière et 9 rbds air est
engagé pour rédiger les communiqués de
presse envoyés aux alliés william dana
owens homme de lettres alors très connus
travaille pour le bureau de la presse
étrangère de krill mary pickford et les
autres stars de cinéma prêtent leur
concours au spectacle la comédienne
marie dressler est inimitable quand elle
mime l'alertent ok zerbib on n'ose
imaginer des gags jamais vu sur la scène
ou à l'écran
charlie chaplin et douglas fairbanks
faisant équipe avec un jeune champion
poids léger jack mc
ça
à
m
un seul but cette campagne de presse
souder le peuple américain d'une masse
métallique chauffée à blanc lui a
insufflé la fraternité dévouement le
courage et la détermination de combattre
jusqu'à la mort année jusqu'au bout des
crimes à ses équipes d'artistes
l'auteur des posteurs les plus célèbres
de la guerre est un illustrateur le
magazine james mangold flac
ils célèbrent un nouveau héros comme les
artistes les écrivains à l'ehpad les
sculpteurs les auteurs de chansons un
héros que l'on appelle le doute boys
à
le recrutement qui débat en juillet 1917
fédéraux potentiel de près de 3 millions
de jeunes américains qui sont invités à
faire honneur à l'uniforme les familles
américaines ont à nouveau passe temps le
dimanche rendre visite au dubai dans
leur camp
les parents et les amis sont là ne
parade des gens importants commencent
par exemple celle de bilson des
l'évangéliste de la ligue nationale qui
multiplie les sermons inspiré détruisez
l'ennemi baleiniers l'autocratie
les soldats lui répondre en chantant
à
là
le président wilson n'hésite pas à
monter à cheval pour visiter les camps
et rencontrer les dogons mary wilson ne
reconnaît plus sa capitale washington et
est souvent décrite comme une ville
somnolente voilà qu'elle se réveille et
pousse comme un champignon
les services gouvernementaux enfle
démesurément on compte les nouvelles
agences par douzaines les registres
fédéraux où s'additionnent les
traitements des fonctionnaires ont
doublé les employés de la maison blanche
sont plus d'un million contre 500 milles
avant la guerre le gouvernement doit
tout payer et la guerre exige une
organisation démultipliés pour faire
face à tous les devoirs y compris la
croix-rouge et l'approvisionnement des
alliés en vivre
au prix d'un dollar l'année le
gouvernement s'assure les services de
ses plus distingués citoyens une armée
d'hommes d'affaires des volontaires du
calibre de thomas edison et de bernard
baruch agréé ford s'occupe de la
production
un observateur appelle la maison blanche
une maison de fous patriotique
la moyenne d'âge des membres de cabinets
présidentiels et de 54 ans
ces sommes ne sont pas mobilisables mais
il entre dans la guerre avec tout leur
esprit d'efficacité maca de haut le
secrétaire au trésor et le gendre de
wilson franklin delano roosevelt est à
la marine l'assistant de daniel le
gouvernement par la publicité de la
guerre est constamment sous les yeux du
public
un nouvel armement devient l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse le président
wilson lui même et du sculpteur la
guerre néo tom baker un des nouveaux
venus au gouvernement herbert tovar
devient vite familiers aux américains
après avoir organisé la campagne
mondiale d'assistance à la belgique
il est chargé du programme alimentaire
intérieur
le maître mot de la campagne de presse à
l'adresse des maîtresses de maison est
ménagé la nourriture le public traduit
ou vers is et c'est ainsi qu'on devient
populaire dans les champs on dit aux
femmes aux enfants qui travaillent fait
un travail d'homme
oh
à
m
l'amour ne change pas mais la condition
des mers change
elle ne sera jamais plus la même après
la guerre les femmes américaines ont
appris à travailler comme les hommes
cela leur fournit des arguments pour
réclamer l'égalité complète et d'abord
des droits civiques
un amendement spéciale leur donnera
satisfaction comment les empêcher de
voter dit un slogan alors qu'elles nous
ont aidés à gagner la guerre
là
l'effort de guerre ne produit pas que
des héros ou de charmante héroïne
il y a aussi les insoumis ils font
partie de l'histoire de cette année 1917
là
à
mon
nous sommes à birmingham dans l'alabama
un insoumis et chasser de la ville par
ses voisins les pénalités qui frappe les
insoumis sont sévères en raison de la
hausse du sentiment patriotique et des
règles très précises du recrutement
celui qui a voulu échapper à
l'incorporation en disparaissant est un
jeune sportif plein de santé il
s'appelle crover crève l'orgue bergdoll
il devient bientôt célèbre comme l'homme
le plus haï d'amérique
l'homme le plus haï du monde est
naturellement le désert dans les films
de propagande
il est constamment tourné en dérision un
pamphlet du gouvernement le décrit comme
un satan prochain
si l'enfer était dans l'eau mur écrit
belison des nous trouve rien sur ses
murs mais dnd germanais comme marque de
fabrique
les slogans anti allemands deviennent de
plus en plus violents un professeur de
l'université d'harvard n'hésite pas à
décrire la musique de wagner comme un
mélange d'agressivité de lubricité et de
trucages on boycotte ont pu parfois les
magasins tenus par des germano américain
il est interdit d' apprendre aux enfants
l'allemand dans les écoles wilson
regrette que l'esprit de guerre
deviennent vulgaire à tolérant
populacier l'hiver 2009 117 est un des
plus rudes que l'amérique est connu sur
la côte est
le temps est maussade des tempêtes de
neige nuisent au moral des civils qui ne
reçoivent pas d'europe la moindre
nouvelle encourageante avec la neige au
patauge dans les rues de new york
les tornades blanche balaye la ville on
s'abrite derrière des pans de mur quand
on le blizzard
depuis neuf mois l'amérique est en
guerre quatre divisions complètes ont
été expédiés outre océans chaque semaine
par de nouvelles unités rien ne bouge
pour autant sur le fond de l'ouest
le public attend avec impatience des
nouvelles de victoire il reçoit
seulement les listes des premiers
américains tués
on met en sourdine l'esprit de joyeux
départ à la guerre les adieux dans les
ports deviennent plus sombre chaque jour
est une bataille sur le front intérieur
il faut acheminer des quantités énormes
de nourriture et de charbon
le long des voies ferrées fatigué il
faut les remettre en état pour conduire
à terme l'effort de guerre
les wagons doivent transporter les
renforts les vivent les munitions
assurer la survie de la nation
abba
la production de guerre est freinée par
de nombreux handicaps les industriels
doivent se reconnaître dans les
instructions contradictoires qui
proviennent des fameux comité de guerre
ou gouvernementaux pour l'action n'est
pas coordonnée la maison de fous
patriotique de washington est devenu
dans les journaux la maison de fous
bureaucratique
l'atmosphère est lourde au capitole la
foule attend sur les marches le résultat
du scrutin
l'administration wilson est combattu par
des sénateurs républicains comme enrique
routledge comme le président theodore
roosevelt mais aussi par un sénateur
démocrate george chamberlain qui
critiquent l'inefficacité des bureaux un
tsar de l'économie bernard barucq est
chargé alors par wilson de faire sortir
du marasme l'industrie de galère
maroc se met aussitôt au travail au
bureau de l'industrie de guerre doté de
pouvoirs extraordinaires
il relance la production par sa
politique volontariste
il n'est responsable que devant
président lui même
il fait adopter un rude régime de
priorité qui discipline l'économie ils
décident d'imposer à l'amérique la
production réglée par l'état
l'automobile reçoit départ plus faible
d'acier l'industrie les corses et ne
reçoit plus rien tout pour les canons -
des tofs pour les blues plus pour les
fuselages l'avion
l'industrie ne parvient cependant pas à
se hausser au rythme des besoins de la
guerre le 4 juillet 1918 jour de
l'indépendance
on lance d'un coup quatre vingt quinze
bateaux mais aucun ne traversera
l'atlantique avant l'armistice les
armements anglais ont la charge de
l'essentiel du trafic
aucun tanks ne sera fabriquée en
amérique les américains reçoivent des
chars français
les canons de 75 les mitrailleuses aussi
sont fournies par les alliés au corps
expéditionnaire américain
l'industrie fini par trouver le bon
rythme
elle manque longtemps main d'oeuvre en
raison des départs massivement échelonné
des travailleurs vers l'europe mais
aussi parce que le développement de
l'industrie de guerre nécessaire le
recrutement d'un nombre sans cesse
accrue de travailleurs les noirs du sud
gagne le nord par milliers attiré par le
piège des hauts salaires
cette migration très importante entraîne
bien tous les conflits des villes comme
philadelphie chicago saint louis dans
l'illinois connaissent les premières
émeutes raciales à saint louis
on compte 37 victimes noir et blanc
un invisible et demi ils s'insinuent
bientôt dans le front de l'intérieur la
grippe qu'en europe on l'appelle
espagnole et qui tuent par milliers on
compte bientôt cinq cent mille morts et
les masques sont obligatoires dans
certains états ne suffisent pas à
enrayer le fléau la grippe aura tué
quatre fois plus d'américains offrant
que les allemands une autre maladie
s'abat sur les états unis
la suspicion au nom du patriotisme
certains se croient autorisés à traquer
tous les ennemis déjà inscrits sur leur
liste noire les embusqués les insoumis
les pacifistes qui condamne la guerre
les troupes de travailleurs mécontents
les immigrés récents mais à l'étranger
wilson avait raison d'avoir peur le
désir de conformité occupe soudas le
premier plan dans la vie de la nation
le gouvernement essaye d'appliquer la
loi lui même d'écarter la populace on
l'accusent de mollesse de tiédeur dans
la répression des mots des pros
allemande
il en vient à supprimer la liberté
d'expression et d'opinion
un groupe de contestataires les
travailleurs industriels du monde et
dissout 1200 ses membres sont arrêtés
dans l'arizona
on les expédie au nouveau mexique où il
ne risque pas de porter atteinte à la
sécurité des états unis
on leur reproche de prêcher à grève est
d'être des anarchistes
les agents fédéraux saisissent tous les
dossiers
le leader big bill fait wood est arrêté
il en va de même pour tous les
responsables
on se moquait des anarchistes ont les
traités de singles et voilà qu'ils
deviennent des dangers pour la sécurité
nationale
on arrête un des chefs du parti
socialiste gène d'eps candidat à la
présidence des états unis en 1912
on lui reproche d'avoir prononcé un
discours contre l'effort de guerre
il est condamné à dix ans de prison
c'est pousser loin le réarmement moral
que de persécuter tous les dissidents
wilson n'hésite pas
des images triomphale de corps
expéditionnaire américain
ces engagements héroïques sont exploités
par la propagande intérieur et apaise
les doutes de la conscience nationale
on est sûrs pendant l'été 2009 118 que
les américains avec leurs alliés vont
lancer la dernière offensive
celle qui aura raison du sact en
allemand et les soldats au front pense
déjà à la victoire
c'est du moins ce qu'explique aux
américains les films de propagande
non
quand le président wilson se manifestent
dans les rues de washington
c'est toujours pour encourager les
fortes guèye est célébré le courage des
soldats du droit le président wilson
veut absolument convaincre les
américains que la guerre en europe et
bien leur guerre les soldats du front en
sont ils convaincus avec les français
avec les anglais il n'arrête pas de
chanter
on attend
j'étais lent doux et tout est pris en
huit saisons
tout dans était lent
tout est prêt à répondre aux leurs
à
et c'est le no
tout est prêt
c'est vrai
bah ouais
harry est selon l'oms
tout est parfait
pas si les tories
passé
tae
et ils sont dans louis tout est prévu
ils ont amené tout haut qu'il se
rendrait de thé par la vie je suis
les plats de riz vers moi
ouais
et souvent